what does true evil
look like it's a question that many
screenplays and anime have failed to
answer over the years
and mahito is one of the best answers i
have come across in a long
while and in this video i will explain
to you exactly
why why this handsome little
frankenstein here is one of the most
eerie repulsive and
horrifying villains in all of anime
a villain that clearly has been
carefully crafted with a clever mix of
human psychology and
gege akutami's ingenious storytelling
abilities
to creep the hell out of you and make
you loathe him
with every pore of your body a core
piece of what makes the story of jujutsu
kaisen
so fantastic that and what's the deal
with all the hands
this is the story of the most horrible
and
human curse of them all
[Music]
imma
i've already discussed one of the three
major villains of yuzukaisen
and yet just like ghetto maito is a
completely
different type of antagonist all three
of them represent fundamentally
different versions of evil which
makes the story so much more interesting
and versatile
this seems like a good time for a drink
and a cold calculated speech with
sinister
overtones and yet out of all three
mahito is the only one that akutami has
created with the intent
to portray true evil the most dangerous
and vile cursed spirit in the story
right now and i would even go so far as
to say
overall but as you've probably already
figured out majito's horror lies not
within how powerful he is but in his
personality
don't you think it's interesting that he
is the only curse that takes the form of
a human in the story
mato is all soul this and hands that oh
and
he has the same blue eyes that gojo has
the genius of mike does character that
will be crystal clear once you make it
to the end of this video
is completely based on the unique role
he takes in the jude's worlds despite
being teased to us as one of the most
scary curses
what stands out most about maesto is
actually his extremely
human appearance his frankenstein-esque
look paired with a quite extroverted and
curious personality as well as a soft
and
kind voice that lets every hair on my
neck stand on end
at first glance make him hard to
differentiate from the equal quirky
looking jutsu students
in fact it even takes quite a while
before we even get the sense that this
is actually the most purely evil
character
in all of this story especially his
early relationship with the harshly
bullied jumper
creates the initial illusion that this
might actually be an
exceptionally nice curse well you know
how that turned out in the end
serves as the embodiment of human
selfishness
cruelty and desire if you pay close
attention you will see that
all of his terrible traits and flaws are
perfectly
human ones human pettiness human
jealousy human fickleness
mashtoe represents all the bad that
humans do to themselves
and to others the very worst of us
what akutami has done here is
masterfully embody the moral theme of
his story
into this one character curses versus
humans because just like yuji is both
human
and curse majito is also both curse
and human and this parallel is no
accident
there are no accidents in general as the
main antagonist of the major first part
of the story majito's most
obvious role is in being a foil to the
protagonist
as often is the case these two
characters mirror each other in many
ways and find themselves
inextricably drawn to each other both
itadori
and mahito are newcomers to the jutsu
game itadori was just a regular high
school dude until the other day while
makito has only quite recently been
awakened in the first place
now this is just me speculating but i
would bet my left ball that someone had
their hands in creating my dough no pun
intended
i mean the guy literally is stitched
together
but we'll have to wait and see
nonetheless both of them are
extraordinarily powerful and have very
polarizing views of the world
as becomes very clear in their first
encounter and anonymity
both of them are basically children
they both want to get stronger test
their abilities and have their influence
on the world while responsibly
thinking through their actions and
motivations just kidding they're of
course both crazily impulse driven and
keep dramatically underestimating those
around them
both itadori and miketo live in their
own little world where they are the
hunters
the gojos who force their will on the
world
yuji trying to save anyone and anything
that moves and mashtoe
literally going full reptile brain
basically only ever following
every impulse he ever has food kill
play whoa
with a child's curiosity is testing his
own powers
learning about the world and even
spending time with humans to transfigure
out how they work
tonight
the funny thing is that mahito's biggest
desire
is proving to himself and to everyone
else that he
is the purest curse the king of curses
if you will
sorry he tries to convince jeonpei to
live more like a curse and yet the big
irony here
is that mahito actually doesn't get how
curses really are take the other
intelligent curses that he's with
jogo hanami and baby cthulhu these guys
are probably
ancient born from people's fear of
nature itself
they behave quite differently from maito
yes they're all somewhat murderous and
hateful towards humans
and they all do seem to be dominated by
the impulses
but they also plan ahead they have a
higher purpose that they're willing to
die for
and they even care about their comrades
hell let's be real here nanami is
probably nicer than
half of the jutsu sorcerers themselves
maito on the other hand
is like a textbook sociopath he does
everything impulsively he manipulates
those around him for his own sake and
when things get tough
he decides to run and afterwards is
super smug about it
and he doesn't really care about the
other curses around him
now i'm gonna drop a big bombshell on
you here and if you didn't know this
you'll have to subscribe
jiu-jitsu kaisen is not only heavily
inspired by other shonen like bleach or
hunter hunter it is also
filled to the brim with the
psychological concept of freud and jung
who both are considered the founders of
modern psychoanalysis
now while both of these men had very
different models of the human mind
both of them also had the theme of the
it the ego or the shadow that basically
describes the unconscious part of our
personality
that you're unaware of but that drives
your basic needs
desires and instincts compared to our
more active conscious minds
well does man do you think need to have
the concept of sin and evil to live with
is this part of our nature
well obviously and of a redeemer
that is a an inevitable consequence it's
something that nowadays you might
stumble across as the feeling versus the
thinking brain and while we all love to
think that we make rational decisions
all the time guess what the feeling
brain
is in command as the psychologist
jonathan hyde put it we're basically the
elephant and
it's writer we can consciously try to
steer our feeling brain in the direction
we want to go
but if the elephant really wants to do
something it'll do it
and there's nothing you can do about it
mashtoe is the embodiment of
exactly that he is pure feeling brain
pure instinct pure pleasure pure doing
what feels good
in the moment he is only that no
emotions and no rationale something that
even the other curses do have to some
extent
and that is exactly what makes mahito so
absolutely terrifying why he creeps you
the [ __ ] out
mato is a mirror for us humans in which
we see our rawest and darkest
instincts reflected right back at us in
other words
mahito is the essence of human evil and
human darkness
compiled into one character and the
reason why itadori specifically hates
him so much
is exactly because of that
he sees himself reflected in mahito all
the stuff that he feels insecure about
his values and ideals itadori's big
thing
is saving people and under no
circumstances hurt them
and yet mahito not only plays with the
life of his own comrades but he also
forces yuji to kill himself
to kill himself and break his own rules
but i think the true reason here lies
even a bit deeper
consider this scene here where gojo
assesses yuji's personality
and condemns killing but he has no
problem
right from the start to absolutely
decimate curses even though they still
take the form of
living creatures to him curses are
basically all the same their existence
doesn't have
any worth in itself and he doesn't
flinch to terminate them if necessary
does that sound vaguely
majito shows yuji that they're pretty
much the same
just on opposite sides and the fact that
the lines between
humans and curses keep blurring more and
more as the story continues
just places more contrast on this fact
mato in a
very interesting way slowly but steadily
forces yuji to deal with his own
insecurities
his own values and his own hypocrisy as
a person it's not good enough to just
think that every human life is valuable
he now has to find an answer as to
why and we can see this clash of their
ideals in how
both of them try to push jumpe to act in
their
sense of their respective values
[Music]
but there is even more humanity in
makhto that makes his horror and
evil seem even greater than it already
is
if i were to ask you why x random psycho
monster
in why scary movie is evil you might say
something like well she is evil because
she doesn't have a heart or a soul
so what does akutami do make mahito all
about
just that
and manipulate souls the essence of
everything
and so for him the soul is nothing
special but just something else that is
just
there no difference between a plant or
an ant or
a human except for human reasoning
which is exactly what mato despises the
most
he simply transforms and plays with
people souls
just to try out his powers using
people's lives and their death to break
yuji exhilarating the harrowing fact
that mahito is playing with the most
valuable thing a human has their soul
their essence
which at least in the jujutsu world is a
very real thing
is wonderfully represented by the
concept of
hence
has the power to touch the essence of
who you
are his hands are literally the touch of
death and
that's also what makes mashito so
brilliant as a piece of writing he
represents you as a human
but also death itself it's all torment
violence and cruelty notice how people
keep reflecting on their ideas about
and their relationship to death whenever
they come into contact with maito
nanami jumpei itadori looking at machto
not only mirrors human life
it also mirrors human death the essence
of human experience itself
and that is an absolutely terrifying
thing to do
contemplating our own mortality and
faultiness which is exactly why mahto in
my eyes
is absolutely perfectly written evil
something that as akutami mentioned in
an interview he was
absolutely going for so is mahito
all evil then no character arc except
growing stronger and more cruel i would
say
kind of not really though maito's answer
to the central moral question of the
story
what does it mean to live a good life
worth living
it's pretty simple life is worthless so
i should just enjoy myself
and follow my instincts now can we
actually say that this is wrong
well i think we can and i hope you do as
well the answer that akutami is going
for
for all his characters is that a good
life worth living
always includes forming relationships
and bonds with others
you can even see the curses doing it in
their small little cursed family
where they all care for each other in
short the moral of jutsu kaisen
is that true happiness and purpose comes
from acting compassionate towards others
that's why mahito is wrong and the fact
that he tries
so hard to be the perfect curse just
underlines how
human he is this irony is actually
wonderfully represented by his name
do you know what mahito literally means
true
human yeah ironic maito is on a journey
to figure out the essence of his own
soul
who he really is and at some point he
might have to face the fact
that he's actually more human than curse
and i really hope we get to see more of
that as i think he is the
perfect antagonist for yuji in the story
don't get me wrong sukuna is absolutely
fantastic but he's way too complex and
cool in my opinion to have the same
sense of evil and
horror that majito spreads on such a
fundamental level
now for the bonus payoff of this video
thanks for watching this far
why does majito also have this beautiful
blue eye that reminds us
so much of gojo
moody i think that this is done quite on
purpose as the two share some
very interesting traits their body
language especially their eyes
radiate absolute certainty of their
superiority they might appear childish
and frivolous on the surface but if you
plunge into their depths they have a
deeper understanding of themselves
and their desires than most other
characters in the series
they might not get other people but
that's not really their priority either
and as we know the eyes are the gates to
the soul
what makes them so special is that both
mahto and gojo
can see things that others can't
gojo's six eyes allow him to perceive
everything about a person
while mahito is capable of seeing the
soul itself
this means that both of them see
everything which results in both of them
being unable to see
people as individuals and that's why
majito
has the same blue eyes as gojol as we
all know though what is much more
important than your soul
is having a well-defined six-pack which
is why the next video is about
[Music]
make sure to watch toto's video here
thanks for watching peace my best